- I've been thinking about
this concept for a long time,
which is everybody who's driving right now
who wants to build a huge business,
I don't think really thinks
that kindness and empathy
and compassion and patience
are core to building an empire.
And I thought I was the guy to write it
because so much of what I've built
and what I'm going to
build is based on things
that your grandma would say you should do.
And I don't think that's
what people think about
when they're gonna build
a $100 million company.
They think sharp elbows,
I'm gonna out negotiate.
They think sports.
- Yeah
And I think what sportsmen
and women do after a game
where they hug and they talk
and, you know, as a fan, I get upset
when they Jets lose an
American football game
and then are hugging and hanging out
with the opponents after, I get mad.
(everyone laughing)
- [Kris] What are you doing!
- Correct.
But that's exactly what
I think is required
of building a big business
and I thought I was the guy to write it.
- [Kris] We hear this word NFT.
- Yes.
- [Kris] We think we understand it
or some of us have absolutely no idea.
- Or a big part of people think
it's a scam and it's a fad.
- And it's coming up on
influencer's social media sites
and you're like, well, I'm
not gonna get into this,
people will laugh, Oh, you're doing NFTs.
You have really shown the world
and you've pioneered it in
your platform of 9 million,
just on Instagram alone
of what NFTs can do and
how they can operate.
Can you explain to someone right now
and I know you've been
asked this question before,
explain in basic terms, what an NFT is?
- It's, let me say this
before I answer that question.
Everybody who's listening right now
is going to struggle with the concept
because they're bringing
their internet brain
to the blockchain.
Let me say that one more time.
The blockchain is such
a different platform
than the internet, that when I
tell you that what an NFT is,
is it's a digital asset that you own.
Most people don't understand
that because they're like,
well, that doesn't work on the internet,
I can right click and save the image.
- [Kris] Sure.
- So, the same way that in
1994, 95, 96, when I told people
that people would buy wine on the internet
and everybody who was 20, 30, 40, 50,
thought that was stupid.
Most people who think NFTs are stupid,
don't realize that they've become
their mom and dad and grandparents.
Just like they thought
the internet was stupid,
email was stupid, the iPhone was stupid,
social media was stupid,
online dating was stupid.
People don't realize that
they are missing the boat
on this technology.
But the answer to your question is,
an NFT is a non fungible token
which is a digital asset
that you actually own.
And when people say,
well, why would I wanna
own something digitally?
I'd need to hold it.
Well, a lot of people
who are driving right now
want a blue check mark on
their Instagram account,
and guess what? You don't hold that.
A lot of people want 10 million
followers on social media,
you don't hold that.
A lot of people live their life
to take photos on the internet,
you don't hold that.
We are living a digital life.
And if you have children that
are buying skins on Fortnite.
- [Kris] I've my both my
kids love buying skins.
- Well, guess what?
That's a digital asset.
And as we go more digital,
your clout, your status,
your need to communicate
is happening more digitally
than it's happening in real life.
People do things just for
a photo on social media.
It's human psychology.
Last of all, it's a smart contract.
Meaning, the digital asset
can also mean something on the back end.
So for example, I have a
huge business conference
in Minnesota in May, called VeeCon.
It's like a south by Southwests
Coachella of business.
And the only way you can get in
is if you own a VeeFriend,
it is the ticket.
- [Kris] You're also opening up
the first NFT restaurant in the world?
- That's right.
Fly Fish Club, which will open next year,
early next year in New York City.
- [Kris] Can I get membership?
- If you buy it.
(everyone laughing)
- [Kris] That's why he's so rich.
- But it's super interesting,
it's super interesting.
A lot of people right now,
especially in this town,
they pay for a membership,
country clubs, Soho
house, all these things,
but you pay, you don't own an asset.
With NFTs, your membership is an NFT,
but if you decide after three months,
you don't want to come anymore.
You put it on a blockchain
and you sell it.
It's creating a world where
your access or your membership
becomes an asset, not an expense.
- [Kris] I understand that.
- So think about that.
- [Kris] So the NFT restaurant
that you're opening up,
it's not a physical restaurant?
- Oh, it's a physical restaurant.
- [Kris] I'll be able to walk
into this thing if I want.
- Yeah, this is not the metaverse,
which I think is much further
away than people think.
I don't think we're living in VR.
And people mix Metaverse and
NFT, they're separate things.
This is a physical restaurant
that is gonna be wildly premium,
large location, highly in demand
that the NFT is just your membership.
And so, that will open in Q1 of next year.
- [Kris] Can't wait for it.
Gary Vee in the studio, once again,
give a big round of applause.
(everyone cheering)
- [Everyone] Gary, Gary, Gary,
- I like this.
- [Everyone] Gary, Gary, Gary.
- [Kris] And that's true, Gary.
Okay, the book, come on.
You're here in Dubai, the
Emirates Lit Festival.
This is your book.
"Twelve and a Half: Leveraging
the Emotional Ingredients
Necessary for Business Success".
I look at the back and I
love already what I see.
Gratitude, self-awareness, accountability.
- Can we talk about accountability?
- Yeah, sure.
- Yes.
- Like, talk about something
the world desperately needs.
We wanna blame the algorithm,
we wanna blame our parents,
we wanna blame the government,
we wanna blame everything.
- [Kris] Yep.
- We have become addicted
with pointing fingers
and nobody wants to point
the thumb at themselves.
I believe most people's unhappiness
that are listening right now,
are completely predicated on
their lack of accountability.
If you are unhappy,
you are actually in a position to fix it.
If you are listening to this,
if you are listening to this,
you were of the means to fix it.
And I think that accountability
is the breakthrough of the next decade,
because we've gotten very cozy
with not being accountable.
- [Kris] Makes sense.
- Like, you're not happy
about your boyfriend?
Break up with him.
- [Kris] Yeah.
As a matter of fact, everybody
in Dubai right now listening,
call your boyfriend that
you're unhappy with,
and break up.
- [Kris] Let's do it on the radio.
(laughing)
- I mean, but Rossi, it's important.
Like, you can.
You don't like the country you're in?
Move.
- [Kris] Sure.
- [Presenter] You're
blaming the situation,
but you should turn it
and look at yourself.
- And here's the point,
whether you're right or wrong,
your mother might be poisonous.
But the second you take control
of it, you become happier.
Whether you're right or wrong about like,
I think everything is my fault.
I'm logical to know that
not everything is my fault,
but the default of thinking
everything is my fault,
actually makes me happy.
- [Presenter] I get that.
- [Kris] Let's talk about
number nine on your book.
And it's one that I've got here,
which I've told you about, patience.
- Yes.
- [Kris] Because I believe that,
could you give us your views
on just that word, patience?
- The lack of it is also a huge factor
to why people are unhappy.
Everybody's looking for
so much outside validation
that they're impatient.
They wanna show everybody
that they're successful,
thus, they're rushing into things.
You have 23 year olds
who think that they don't
have their life figured out,
yet they're living for another 80 years.
Patience has been huge for me.
Most people hear the word patience
and have it confused with complacency,
laziness, lack of ambition,
it's not true.
I actually think patience
has been foundational in my success.
I decided to build my
dad's business for him
for the first 12 years of my career.
That required huge patience
from somebody who thought they were great.
I didn't even start
quote-unquote until I was 34.
Patience is huge, it's huge.
And people don't wanna do it
'cause they want instant gratification.
And more importantly,
instant outside validation.
- [Kris] I like it.
"Twelve and a Half: Leveraging
the Emotional Ingredients
Necessary for Business Success".
It's out right now. Gary Veeaynerchuk.
And he's with us in studio.
He's gonna answer a few of your questions.
I know that we've got a
few on hold right now.
I'm just gonna ask them to hold.
Real quickly.
Maz Hakim, who is our
night show, Maz and James.
Rarely have I ever seen
her in the morning.
There's probably, in my 13-year career.
(everyone laughing)
I think I've seen you once in my studio
at this time.
- [Maz] Yeah.
- [Kris] And you have done a Garyvee.
You've got up Maz.
- I'm very excited.
- [Kris] There it is.
- One of my great
accomplishments of my career.
- [Kris] That's number 13 in here, okay?
Maz, no honestly, I know
that you're a huge fan.
You were messaging me last week
when you heard Gary was coming
in, what do you wanna say?
- [Maz] I just wanna say I
follow everything you do, Gary.
I actually bought a few
NFTs based on what you said.
I bought the "Mona Lisa".
- Really?
- [Maz] From Curio Cards
and then I sold it.
- I'm so proud of you.
- [Maz] Yeah. So, I
follow everything you do.
- [Kris] You never told us
about you doing all this NFT stuff.
- [James] Did you make any money?
- [Maz] I made a bit of money,
but then I had to sell it.
- [James] Why?
- [Maz] I've signed up for.
- She needed the cash.
- [Kris] Ah. Okay.
And you've got your own business as well.
I'm sure Gary's helped you
do your own thing as well.
- [Maz] Absolutely.
- [Kris] These jackets that she wears
are so amazing.
- So cool.
- [Kris] They're so cool.
- [Maz] So they're made by Afghan women,
it's called Espand by Maz.
- Love.
- [Maz] And I've actually brought one.
- Thank you.
- [Kris] Is it a male or female one?
- [Maz] it's a female.
- It's gorgeous.
And so, what makes you,
like, what pushed you to do it?
- [Maz] So actually, I
saw you here in the studio
two years ago and the concept
originally started with bags.
- Yes.
- [Maz] But I'm originally
from Afghanistan.
And so, it pays homage to my-
- Of course, your roots
- [Maz] Relatives and my roots.
- [Kris] I heard your parents migrated
from Afghanistan to Australia,
and now like, they're so successful,
like, Maz on the radio, your sister is on,
- [Maz] BBC.
- [Kris] BBC.
She's like the main girl on BBC.
- This is a media family empire.
- [Kris] And they migrated
from Afghanistan with nothing,
went to Australia.
- Are you producing a lot of
TikTok content for the jackets?
- [Maz] Not enough.
- This is very disappointing.
- [Everyone] Yeah.
- [Kris] You tell her.
'Cause you told me that as
well, a couple years ago.
- And?
- [Kris] Yeah, we've picked up our game.
It's still not at the camera.
- No, I know.
I doubt, Kris, I double
checked on the way here.
(laughing)
Yes I did.
You are not...
Listen.
When it's like telling
someone they have to exercise
and they're like, I'm doing exercise,
I'm like, you walked on the
treadmill for two minutes.
(laughing)
That's where you're at right now. I know.
Yeah. So don't point fingers.
You saw what you just did?
(laughs)
TikTok.
TikTok, I'm telling you,
it's such a visual platform.
All the attention is there right now.
You can go viral, organically,
not have to pay ads.
It's very unusual.
It's a very special platform.
And for what you're doing,
it's highly required.
- [Maz] Thank you so much.
Yeah, I find Instagram ads
don't really work for me.
- They can, but they're
expensive now, it's mature.
When you know, if I was here in 2013,
I would've been like Instagram,
Instagram, Instagram.
Attention on social media
is like real estate.
You wanna buy it early enough,
because once it becomes
mature, it becomes expensive.
Right?
- [Kris] Yeah.
- So, right now TikTok
is appropriately priced.
- [Maz] Okay.
- [Kris] All right.
Listen, Maz,
Amazing. That was good eh?
- [Maz] Yeah, yeah very good, thanks.
- [Kris] I don't need a
thanks, I don't need a thanks.
Just say it one more time though.
(laughing)
- [Kris] All right. More with Garyvee.
Next, your questions.
And he's gonna actually help
us do something on the show.
You don't know what
you're launching for us,
but you're gonna help us
launch something, okay?
- As long as it's from Priti, then I'm in.
(everyone cheering)
- Definitely not from me.
- [Kris] It's cool you like it.
Do you ever get exhausted to
just like, offering advice?
- Nah.
Nah, it's too humbling.
- [James] Yeah.
- You know.
(indistinct)
Yeah, but it's like,
I'm almost so profoundly humbled by it
that I'm incapable of seeing
the negative aspects of it.
You know?
It's like what a nice thing.
(indistinct chatter)
- Does anybody know the
Wi-Fi? Is it ARN Guest?
Do you guys see it?
- [Maz] It's like a secret,
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Maz] Secret password that they give us.
- [Kris] Do you wanna just hotspot me?
- Sure.
- [Kris] But I'm on a Samsung.
- Will that work with me or?
- [Maz] I have my a hotspot.
- [Kris] Okay. It's on.
It should be, you should see it.
- Is it 'super handsome dude 49'?
(laughing)
- [Kris] It's Android AP.
- I see it.
And then it's just password one to eight.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight.
- [James] What was the
other direct (indistinct)
- [Kris] All right. 31.
He's got it right.
So back to back Gary
Vee. is in the studio.
He lands in the city
and then, it's just
go, go, go, go, go, go,
you just don't stop,
you're in and out, right?
- Yeah. I mean, you know,
I'm a big fan of maximizing
all the time, right?
So we're here and we wanna see everybody.
- [Kris] Don't waste time, right?
- But don't burn yourself out, right?
Like, don't waste time,
but don't get it twisted,
I got good eight hours of
sleep on the flight out here,
and then we got in late
and I got another six.
Like, I'm all about sleep.
It's just that when I'm awake,
I wanna be as efficient as possible.
- [Kris] One personal question about you,
do you enjoy driving cars?
Do you have a bunch of cars?
Like, you know, we know you got money,
you don't buy cars?
- I don't.
I don't really understand the value,
like to me, it's all about
everyone has different things they like.
I don't understand the
performance of a car.
I don't wanna go fast.
Like, that's not my jam.
- [Kris] That's not your thing?
- No.
- [James] Well, like no jewelry either?
- No, no jewelry.
Like, I don't like things,
I like the game.
I like the process of
being an entrepreneur.
I don't like the things
that come along with
entrepreneurship, I really don't.
I don't need the trophies,
I just need to play my game.
- [Kris] A lot of people been
messaging us this morning,
wanting some advice from Gary Vee.
Again, he's here in the city
for the Emirates Lit festival.
The book is out.
Now, initially...
Well, Mo, let's get you on mate, Mo?
You're on with Gary. We've
got a few minutes here.
What did you wanna ask him?
- [Mo] Hey Gary.
- Hey Mo.
- [Mo] Welcome to Dubai.
- Thank you, my friend.
- [Mo] So, Gary, I've been
making some side business
or working on some side
business the past few years.
And it's been, I'm now making
more than double my salary, actually.
- Interesting.
- [Mo] But I'm till insecure about,
you know, leaving the job.
I mean, I am not really ready
to take the leap of faith.
And I've been trying hard to understand
what should I do for
the last eight months.
So I thought this is a
great opportunity to ask.
- Thank you, my friend.
My belief is that fear is powerful
and however you were brought up
or what your ideology is on safety,
you put having a job on a pedestal,
as something that's secure.
The logic for all of us
listening to you right now
is if you're making double
what you make in there,
it seems like a very obvious step.
But I'm empathetic that you're
scared to make that jump.
My thing to remind you
and people out there in
a similar situation is,
it's not very hard to get another job
if you fail, if you leave this job.
And so for me, if we were friends
and we talked all the time,
the thing I would always
remind you every day is,
if you take the leap of faith
and some reason it doesn't work,
which by the way, if you're
making double your salary
as a side hustle,
if you give a 100% of your time to that,
I have a funny feeling
it's going to work out.
But I would remind you
that you could always
go and get a job again
in the same industry, maybe
for a different company.
Believe it or not and I've seen this,
sometimes for the same company,
'cause they missed you.
That's what I would pound into your head
because whatever you grew up with,
it created an ideology
that a job was safe.
Does that make sense to you, Mo?
- [Mo] Absolutely, Gary.
Thank you very much.
- Listen.
Before you leave, you
need to re-listen to that
over and over and over.
Every human being is the
byproduct of what they listen to.
So if you're listening to
your parents or a plus one
or somebody else that's
saying, no, no, no, no, no,
don't make the jump, you're
not gonna make the jump.
If you listen to somebody who's
saying something practical,
like, take the jump and oh, by
the way, if it doesn't work,
you can always go back,
and if it fails, who cares
about other people's judgment,
then you'll jump.
- [Mo] Yeah, it's coming from Gary Vee,
Of course, I'm gonna jump.
(everyone cheering)
- That's my man. Jump.
- [James] Do it.
- [Kris] Love it.
See you, Mo. Thank you, mate.
- Thanks, Mo
- [Kris] All right. Love.
You know, so many people
are messaging in right now,
but we know that you've gotta run.
Before you do, we wanted to
kick something off this show.
We've been wanting to do this
for nearly about 18 months.
- [James] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kris] We've talked about
doing this on the show.
- [James] Inspired by
your garage sales show.
- [Kris] Yeah. So obviously,
we want to do our,
we're doing the Kris Fade Show swap meet.
- Oh!
- [Kris] We wanna start off
with obviously one object
and we wanna take it
till the end of the year
to see how big we can go.
- The old red paper clip concept.
- [Kris] Correct.
Now, we figure that we've
got you in the studio,
we actually probably could
be starting too high.
- [Maz] Yeah, this is.
- [Kris] But is there anything
that you can provide us with
as our first object?
And then what we'll do,
is we're gonna ask anyone
listening to the show,
- To trade you.
- [Kris] Trade it.
Like, to swap it.
And they may give us something
that's of higher value
to the point where I will
own my own private jet.
- [Maz] Excuse me, excuse me.
(laughing)
This is not about you.
- [Kris] Oh, okay.
- Isn't this all of you?
- [James] Yeah. It's just one item, yeah.
- [Kris] So, one item
and at the end of the-
- Well, let me ask you a question.
Do you wanna feel proud of yourself?
Like, for example, if I give you right now
an hour of my time on Zoom,
the value of that is very high.
- [Kris] That's too high.
- Okay. What about a signed book?
That's nice and humble.
No, you know, Priti, thank
you for flattering me,
but that's not like,
listen, the hour's like
tens and tens and tens
of thousands of dollars.
- [Kris] Can we come back to you for that?
- You mean the hour?
- [All] Yeah.
- Well, you can.
(everyone laughing)
- So, you've got,
listen, I'm gonna put in your court,
you can have a signed book.
- [Kris] Yeah.
- Right? Which is a nice, solid item
that I know a lot of people listening
might want and might
trade you something good.
Or you can take the hour.
Now, let me remind you.
Kids that are born into a lot of wealth,
actually deal with a lot
of anxiety and unhappiness
because they're born on third base.
So if I give you the hour,
nobody's gonna be really impressed
with what you end up with
because your starting
point was remarkable.
- [Kris] I don't wanna start.
The hour, no, what I was
saying to coming back to it,
I'd like to get to like maybe
three months into the journey
and then be like,
yo, we've just got an hour with Gary Vee,
I'm happy to take the,
I still think the book is still too good.
- Well, what about a marker?
Like, a Sharpie.
- [Priti] Why don't you make a doodle?
- That's worth a million dollars.
(everyone laughing)
I don't know if you've heard,
but I'm a pretty big artist now.
My stuff sells at Christie's.
- [Kris] Okay, so, what we'll do,
why don't we lock in,
can we take the hour, are
you being serious like this?
- I'm being dead serious.
That's how much I love you.
I'm absolutely happy to do it.
- [Maz] An hour.
- An hour Zoom in my time
before the end of the year,
likely, June, July, August.
I'm in.
- [James] Well, this is nice.
- Now, to give you a preview
of what just happened,
in six months, Maha's
gonna email me and say,
look, you gotta do that
hour, do you remember?
And I'm gonna be very upset
that I committed to this.
- [Kris] You are.
- But now I'm stuck.
It's on public record.
I'm in.
- [Kris] All right.
- [Maz] Are we taking the hour?
- [Kris] We're taking Gary
Vee's hour. Thank you.
(everyone clapping)
- Now, you understand, we're in Dubai,
by the way, we're in Dubai.
I don't know who listens to this show,
like, you might get offered
a private jet just for that.
You might be done here.
- [Kris] Yeah, this is good. Thank you.
- You're very, you should,
everybody who's listening,
you should see his face right now.
Kris is very excited.
- [Kris] I'm gratituding.
(laughs)
I'm out of accountability of this.
I'm going through everything
in your book right now.
- [James] The best thing is
we get to keep our books.
(laughs)
- [Kris] So what we're gonna do,
we're gonna bank that hour with
Gary Vee, we will bank that.
We will officially kick off
the Kris Fade Show Swap Meet tomorrow
with our first product
or our first object.
Who knows what it's going to be.
- [James] Oh, my God.
- [Kris] Gary Vee, we love you, man.
- I love you back.
- [Kris] Thank you so much
for coming in as usual.
- Thanks for having me.
- [Kris] Go and grab the book.
"Twelve and a Half: Leveraging
the Emotional Ingredients
Necessary for Business Success".
(everyone clapping)
(upbeat music)